down there's the number 16 stitches for
divinson sprigs
the rams issued a statement we're aware
of the reports regarding aaron donald
we're collecting more information have
no further comment at this time what the
rams think doesn't matter this is
something that falls within the
exclusive jurisdiction of the national
football league under the personal
conduct policy the rams can't do
anything about it he's not at work it's
the off season this is where the nfl has
the ability to take action and we know
from experience the nfl ultimately has
the power to do whatever it wants to do
in a situation like this but if there is
some finding that aaron donald did this
he's got to worry about some sort of
punishment from the nfl chris plain and
simple the photo of the eye swollen shut
onto vincent spriggs and if there was a
broken arm suffered at the hands of
aaron donald
these are these are serious matters you
know
guys
when they grow up
sometimes they don't realize you can't
get in a fight like it used to because
when you're a grown man you're going to
inflict serious harm on the other person
and you're responsible for that
criminally potentially and civilly for
any any injuries that the individual
suffers no you're right i mean i mean
that that that that is i think sometimes
it gets lost in translation with
football players they still have this
mindset of like i'm a high school
college like young crazy athlete and you
forget like no you're a grown man with
like a lot at stake and a lot of people
are depending on you definitely i mean
hey what's the old saying like nothing
good happens after 11 p.m i mean isn't
that the old saying there i i don't know
you know one hey aaron donald be like
the last guy you want to mess with on
earth like when it comes to 3 a.m or 4
a.m in the morning i don't know what and
so it's it's dangerous or any other hour
of the day or any hour of the day right
i mean gosh he is one of those guys
where you just be like ah no i'll i'd
rather get punched by mike tyson than
deal with this guy i mean it's a
different animal altogether but yeah
serious allegations and aaron donald
could be in trouble
but when you are aaron donald and you
have that kind of raw physical power at
your disposal it becomes even more
important to exercise restraint at all
times i remember that you know you you
used to say in the movies back in the
70s i haven't heard this line in a long
time but someone would say you know my
hands are registered as lethal weapons
and there was this sense that boxers
aren't allowed to get in fights because
they may kill somebody right right
aaron donald isn't a boxer but he may
kill somebody literally so
look we live in the age of everyone
walking around with the cell phone
device i assume there'll be videos
somewhere it happened out on the street
surveillance cameras are everywhere
somewhere somehow we'll be able to
either show that donald was involved in
this fight or that he wasn't and if he
was the sooner he makes it right with
the vincent spriggs the better off he's
going to be both in the eyes of the
criminal authorities and
the court of roger goodell at 345 park
avenue and it's just one of those things
that you never know
when you're going to hear the news no
there's a player even a star player even
a star
hall of famer one of the best players in
the league
if this happens
the the the and this is my my i just
hope that that the justice is meted out
yeah the same way it would be for
anybody else that that the league
doesn't get caught up in the idea that
aaron donald's a star player i hope they
don't go harder on him because of it and
i hope they don't go easier sometimes
they go harder on the big star because
it's a bigger story when it's a star
versus some backup that nobody cares
about no i know i mean listen we'll see
how i don't want to make any judgments
either but i mean i've been around aaron
donald a few times you know they don't
really get any nicer than the guy
altogether i have a hard time thinking
you know again that he was like going
around looking for somebody to beat up
or something like that you know and i
can honestly say even for a guy like
aaron donald i'll say this story he
might not even be happy but like people
can be stupid at that time of the day
they can they could have a lot of liquid
courage and do a lot of dumb crap i just
want to make sure people know that i
mean i was with a
ex-teammate of mine sean rogers you
remember sean rogers the nose tackle
back in the day mike he's one of the
biggest humans ever i mean we were out
one night and he showed restraint this
guy kept bothering him and bothering him
and bother him and he showed restraint
the whole night the whole night whole
night the guy finally just wouldn't give
up and started to like get really
confrontational and in his face and he
he was you know completely disrespecting
the guy well shawn rogers you know at
all 340 he took his left hand back and
cocked back and knocked the guy across
the room like it was a cartoon you know
and i want to go like yeah i wish he
wouldn't have done that but i also want
to go like damn what was he supposed to
do this guy was gonna you know cause a
problem no matter what so again that's
why i'm just saying let's not judge too
harshly we'll see where it goes yeah
disengage and leave there's a difference
between self-defense and this guy is
just i'm a pain in my ass i'm gonna
punch him across the room like it's a
cartoon i get you disengage and leave
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports